Alright. Let's have something more concrete to work
on. If you've organized events, you've probably used sites
like [UNKNOWN] or eventbrite.com. Well, let's say you wanted
to create an app to organize conferences. That type
of application would need to support at least the
following. A user can register, a user can create
conferences. Users can attend conferences. And of course, it
needs to be accessible both from the browser and
the mobile device. Well, we're going to create such an
application. And it's going to be called Conference Central. And
you're tasked to build it. And since it needs
to support multiple backends, you will use Cloud Endpoints to
create this application. Let's get started with Conference Central,
by having you download the skeleton code. Now, let's
take a quick tour of the completed Conference Central
application that you will build. But before we do that,
let's do a quick demo of the finished application. As
you can see, you're presented with a very nice landing
page for Conference Central. And if we scroll down, you
can see options to view conferences. Create conferences and update your
profile. But, before that, let's sign into the application. Sign
in, we'll use Google Plus sign in. Once we are signed
into the application, we can start to explore the functionality.
I can, for example, go to my profile where my personal
information is stored. I can also show the registered
conferences. So here you can see the name of the
conference. The city where it will be in. The
start date, organizer, how many people are registered to conference.
And how many tickets are available to the conference.
You can also query for different conferences. For example, the
ones you've created. Or the ones that you will
attend. You can also query by other types of properties.
And you can view the details for a conference. You can also of
course, create new conferences. Well that's an
overview of Conference Central. The application that
you will build and run in the Google Cloud. Now it's time for
you to do some work and get you started building Conference Central. Good luck.